كما قال ستيفان دوجري كالمتحدث باسم
الامين العام للامم المتحده ان المنظمات
الدوليه قالقه من احتمال انهيار نظام
الرعايه الصحيه بالكامل في السودان بسبب
القتال المتواصل وحذر من نفاد الطعام
والوقود والامدادات الحيويه الاخرى في
البلاد
الانساني من نفادي الطعام والوقود
والامدادات الحيويه الاخرى في السودان
كثيرون بحاجه شديده الى رعايه طبيه نحن
بحاجه ماسه الى هدنه انسانيه حتى يتمكن
الجرحى والمدنيون من الوصول الى
المستشفيات الناس في الخرطوم لم يتمكنوا
من مغادره منازلهم بامان لشراء الطعام
والمواد الاساسيه الاخرى لايام لا تزال
الاستجابه الانسانيه في السودان معرقله
بشده يجب ان تتوقف الهجمات ضد عمال
الاغاثه ونهب المنشات الانسانيه الان نشعر
بالقلق من احتمال انهيار نظام الرعايه
الصحيه بالكامل في السودان
قال احمد المنطري المدير الاقليمي لمنظمه
الصحه العالميه في شرق البحر الابيض
المتوسط قال ان المستشفيات القليله التي
لا تزال مفتوحه في الخرطوم تعمل في ظروف
خطره وسط نقص شديد للادويه والمستلزمات
الطبيه ونفاذ الطعام وانقطاع الكهرباء
تعاني المستشفيات عموما في السودان ولكن
بالاخص في الخرطوم والمناطق اللي فيه التي
فيها النزاعات
والتي تستقبل المرضى من نقص يعني في الدم
ومشتقاته النقص في المعدات الاخرى اللازمه
لتقديم الخدمات العلاجيه سواء ادوات
جراحيه او مستلزمات طبيه اخرى
ومواد ممكنه للحياه كادويه على سبيل
المثال هناك نقص في
في المياه توفر المياه النظيفه هناك نقص
في الاستمرار الكهرباء هناك نقص في وكود
والغذاء اللازم للمرضى والمقيمين داخل
المستشفيات فهو فعلا فعلا ازمه حقيقيه
يعني مقلقه جدا
يعني الله يستر عن خلال الساعات والايام
الجايه
وصف بكري ابو بكري بشير مدير برامج اطباء
بلا حدود في السودان الوضع في البلاد بانه
غير مسبوق وحذر في مداخله مع الجزيره من
انهيار النظام الصحي بشكل كامل
عدد كبير جدا من المستشفيات الرئيسيه اصبح
خارج نطاق الخدمه كليا او جزئيا اما بسبب
القصف المباشر عن المباني او بسبب نقص
الامتداد كذلك هناك عدد كبير جدا من
الكوادر الصحيه غير قادره على الوصول الى
المستشفيات وغير قادر على الحركه بسبب
القسوه بسبب اطلاق النيران
توجد عدد كبير جدا من الكوادر الطبيه
والصحيه متعبه ومرهقه بعد عمل
اكثر من 72 ساعه متواصله فهذا وضعها يعني
بصراحه مقلق للغايه وقد يؤدي الى انهيار
الخدمه الصحيه كليا